[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions our phone lines are open if
you have a Bible related question give
us a call now at 800 God says that's 800
7297 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact the largest
known meteorite on Earth is the hoba in
Namibia Africa the space Rock was
discovered by chance in 1920 when a
farmer plowing his field with an ox
struck the metallic sounding object with
his plow curious he removed the top soil
to discover a massive Iron Rock 9 ft
across although excavated and declared
to be a National Monument the 66 ton
rectangular meteorite has never been
moved from the spot where it landed
because of its immense weight 132,000 lb
its durability and rem remote sight this
fantastic treasure Still Remains
outdoors unmoved in its original
location and there you got a picture on
the screen for those that are watching
the video right now that's where it
landed that's where it was found too big
to move and it it's out there in the
open withstands the elements makes me
think of uh another unmovable Rock
that's right Pastor I mean it's
incredible that's a big meteor we just
talking before the show you'd think
something that big would have created a
massive crater but a little bit of the
research you did they think maybe it
kind of bounced or skipped or maybe hit
water prior to Landing in that spot yeah
it well it hit the atmosphere they think
at an angle which is part of the reason
it didn't all burn up and um then it
instead of coming down it kind of
skipped along the Earth or something and
it was only covered by um just the top
soil that would have happened through
accumulation which wasn't very deep but
U makes me think about a prophecy in the
Bible of another Stone that flies
through the heavens that is another
durable stone and you can read about
this friends in Daniel 2:34 and 35
Daniel is explaining this Vision to
Nebuchadnezzar you watched while a stone
was cut out without hands which struck
the image on its feet of iron and clay
and broke them in pieces then the iron
and the clay the bronze the silver and
the gold were crushed together and
became like chaff from the summer
threshing floors the wind carried the
them away so that no trace of them was
found and the stone that struck the
image became a great mountain and filled
the whole earth talks about this stone
that U is a symbol of Christ in his
kingdom coming to pulverize all of the
Pagan kingdoms of the world that stone
it's interesting it says a stone Pastor
Ros cut without hands because in the law
of Moses and you and I are reading we're
on the same Bible reading program right
now said if you make an altar do not
lift you cool up upon it because if they
were tempted to carve on it with man's
hands then it turned into an idol pretty
soon and they were to take basic Stone
and um so this stone represents Christ
and his kingdom Jesus said these words
that I speak a wise men Builds on the
Rock Ten Commandments were written on a
rock another symbol of something that is
immovable and enduring that's why I
thought of this hoba meteorite by the
way the word hoba means gift we learned
in the local native language but there's
another immovable Rock of God's word his
truth his law and it it's the standard
by which all will be judged someday
that's right Pastor D it is undoubtedly
the most precious stone on Earth today
you know hidden somewhere in a golden
box there in Jerusalem The Ten
Commandments what makes it so special
isn't the stone but it's the one who
wrote on the stone God of course himself
wrote the T Commandments well are the
Ten Commandments still binding today
well number of Christians say well no
was done away with it's part of the old
Covenant others say no it's still
applicable for us today you know we have
a study guide called written in stone
and it's about the Ten Commandments and
of course if you stop and think for any
short period of time you realize that
for Christians surely God would want us
not to kill or steal or commit adultery
or bear false witness so it makes sense
that no it's still valid even today
absolutely wonder it makes you wonder
why
people would say that uh the Ten
Commandments are part of the old
Covenant that we don't need to keep
anymore MH our study guide is called
written in stone and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
if you haven't read the study guide yet
you need to get it take a look at it the
number to call is 800
83567 47 you can ask for it just say
written in stone we'll be sending it to
you also you can dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then ask for it by name written in stone
now this is for those who are in North
America and Canada if you're outside of
the us and we know we have folks
listening around the world just go to
the Amazing Facts website just
amazingfacts.org
or.com and you'll be able to read it
there well before we go to the phone
lines as we always do Pastor Doug we
like to start with prayer amen dear
father we thank you that we have this
time to be able to open up your word and
study indeed the Bible is a lamp to our
feet a light to our path and it leads us
to a clear and full understanding of
Truth so Lord we invite your spirit to
be with us be those who are listening
wherever they might be in jesus' name
amen amen well Pastor D was kind of an
interesting evening going on here we're
in Northern California for those of you
who are listening if you don't know
where amazing facts is actually in the
Sacramento area where our studios are
located we're right on top of probably
the highest if you can call it it's
bigger than a hill I don't know what not
a mountain but it's a pretty tall high
heill here in in the area and it is
howling outside the wind is just crazy
uh not exaggerating friends we are
having hurricane winds outside and I'm
just so proud of our crew all showed up
that's right and there's trees down
everywhere and power we have no power at
our home and by the way if this program
suddenly goes off the air you'll know
what happened that's right so pray that
the power stays on the power is still on
and the Signal's going out so we're able
to study the word together the first
caller that we have is Jerry listening
in Texas Jerry welcome to Bible answers
live you are on the air hey P hey
pastors good evening appreciate your
program all the time
uh simple question tonight guys was
there a Sabbath before creation uh
another worlds you know uh do they have
a Sabbath well let's talk about it yeah
good question uh as near as we can tell
from the evidence in the Bible the
Sabbath first appears in Genesis chapter
2 and because it's connected with the
revolution of our Earth on its axis and
uh as you know the the the planets go
around the Sun I think the Sabbath is
connected with timekeeping in our world
now does God have other times of rest or
holy days on other unfallen worlds the
Bible doesn't say but uh it first
appears in scripture in connection with
the creation of our planet and these
creatures made in the image of God so it
sounds unique to us and yet it will
continue throughout all eternity you
read about the earth made new and it
continues of course it's our Earth that
is recreated and the New Jerusalem comes
down and God dwells here amongst these
people so yes Sabbath continues for
eternity next qu that we have is Britany
listening in California Britney welcome
to the
program hey
hey hi how are you Britney and your
question
tonight yeah my question is what does
the Bible say about eating a plant-based
diet okay good question um you know
sometimes we have to just defer and say
well the Bible doesn't say anything
about that but actually the Bible does
uh the original diet now when you say
plant-based friends that doesn't mean
you're just eating leaves a plant-based
diet is you know a vegetarian eating
vegetables or things that come from
plants um the original diet from man in
the Garden of Eden was fruits grains
nuts after sin God added vegetables that
would be other parts of the plant the
stock and The Roots so forth of the
leaves and in the new Earth we're going
to be back to We Believe the original
diet so um the doctor actually have
pretty much told us the jury is in and
it is a scientific fact that people that
avoid animal products uh will still
eventually get old and die but they're
going to have a lot less disease and
they going to be a lot healthier you
your chances of having a longer stronger
healthier life with more energy are
going to be connected with eating as
close to the biblical diet as you can we
did an interview here with uh Dr
scharenberg
uh still going he's aund and plus years
old and uh yeah he been a vegetarian
most of his life that's right all right
we have a a study guide that talks about
health it's called God's free health
plan and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who wants to learn more about
what the Bible says about how we can be
healthy the number is 800 835 6747 ask
for the study guide is called God's free
health plan you can also di pound 250 on
your smartphone say Bible answers live
and then ask for that study guide by
name thank you Britany we got Gary in
Illinois Gary you're on Bible answers
live thank you my question comes from
Luke 17 ver 28 in the days of lot they
ate they drank they bought they sold
they planted they built but in the day
that lot went out from Sodom it rained
fire and brimstone from heaven and
destroyed them all even so will it be in
the day when the son of man is revealed
so my question is is the world so big
that uh the tribulation takes place even
as things go on as
normal well when the the Great
Tribulation comes um by the way friends
when we read where Jesus says there's
going to be a great time of trouble and
he mentions this in Matthew 24 it's also
mentioned in Daniel chapter 12 uh you've
got sort of three phases one Jesus was
telling the Jews they were facing a big
time of trouble with the destruction of
Jerusalem and that happened and then he
was telling the church you're going to
face a great time of trouble during the
Dark Age persecution when the church
would flee Into the Wilderness and that
happened but then there's a a great
great time of trouble you read of that
is in the Book of Revelation when the
seven last plagues begin to fall and I
think that's what Gary is talking about
um that's still future that hasn't by by
the time that time of trouble starts
probation is closed and we think it's
going to last very long says in
Revelation that all of her her U plagues
come in a year and a prophetic year is
um a pro day rather a prophetic day is
going to be one year one year yeah so
it'll be within that period of time it
might be less than a year but it's not
going to last longer than a year so um
will people still be on the earth then
yes because that's why Jesus said he
that endures to the end the same will be
saved and the children of Israel were
they they in Egypt when the seven
plagues fell or the 10 plagues yes did
he protect them yes so uh hopefully that
we do have a study guide Gary if you're
interested it's called anything but
secret it talks about the tribulation in
that booklet the number to call is 8835
6747 you can ask for the book it's
called anything but secret we'll be
happy to send it to you in Canada or in
the US you can also get a digital copy
of that by just dialing pound 250 say
Bible answers live and then ask for it
the I forgot the name anything but
secret anything but secret that's right
we've got several titles by the way we
have another one on the second coming
called ultimate Deliverance that's right
sometimes we get mixed up but it's a
great book anything but secret I we'll
send that to you it's a digital download
so you can get it right away thank you
Gary we got uh let's see who else Glenn
in Ohio Glenn welcome to the
program good evening pastors and thank
you very much for taking my
call yes thank you Jesus was born again
by a resurrection I think Peter and
Colossians both say so yet people are
told today they need to come to the
altar be converted get saved and born
again I'm looking for a scripture that
says that that validates that being born
again one that does not contradict 1
John 518a can you help
me all right well a person doesn't
necessarily need to come to the the
altar to be bornn again uh the Apostle
Paul went through a conversion and a new
birth and he was on the road to Damascus
getting ready to persecute Christians
and he had an encounter with Jesus he
spent three days uh praying and fasting
and then uh ananas laid hands on him and
the scales fell from his eyes and you
can be sure he was born again at that
time he had a new birth and he was a new
man and Jesus said you'll know them by
their fruits they start doing something
different
so and of course the famous passage you
find in John chapter 3 Jesus said said
except a man be born of water and of the
spirit he cannot see the kingdom of
heaven now Jesus didn't have to be born
uh not I mean he was born but he didn't
have to be as we refer today born again
because Christ never sinned yeah so
those everyone else has sinned all have
sinned and fallen short of the glory of
God except for Christ so for everyone
else we got to be born again and that is
to receive Jesus as our personal Savior
and for some people the new birth like
Paul is a dramatic sudden occurrence and
they can tell you the date on the
calendar for other people in my case I
sort of read my way into it I think
there was a time I ultimately prayed and
officially asked God into my heart I
don't even remember the date but um as
far as my mind and heart being changed
that happened over a process while I was
reading so it's hard to fix the date
that's why Jesus said the wind blows
where it will and you hear the sound
thereof but you don't know where it came
from and where it's going and so um
sometimes a new birth is like that
thanks Glenn and uh you know we've got
that book three steps to Heaven that
talks about the New Birth we'd be happy
to send you a free copy the number again
is 800 83567 47 ask for the book it's
called three steps to Heaven also you
can get a digital copy by dialing pound
250 on your smartphone all right we got
Dell listening in Nevada Dell welcome to
the
program thank you thank you Pastor for
taking my call yeah um my question
is I I don't eat unclean Meats but if
you look at 1 Corinthians
10:27 and Luke
108 um well uh 1 Corinthians 10:27 it
says if any of those who do not believe
invites you to dinner and you desire to
go eat whatever is set before you asking
no questions for conscience sake and um
Luke 108 is similar to that where it
says whatever city you enter and they
receive you each such things as are set
before you so then what do I do I mean
if they said yeah to good that's a great
question there are um the context of
those is both different first of all
when Jesus sends out the twel apostles
he says go not to the Gentiles go to the
lost sheep of the House of Israel so
they knew right away they were going
into Jewish homes and Christ is saying
don't be finicky about what you eat they
weren't going to be serving them pork
uh that didn't even come into anyone's
mind at that point because they're going
to speak to Jews so he just saying you
know don't say well I want some of this
and not that and he says be thankful for
what they give you Paul it's a different
question Paul is talking about when
Believers were buying meat in the
marketplace and they were only buying
clean Meats because they knew what the
law said they were concerned well was it
sacrificed to an idol now Pastor Ross
there's a place where he says asking no
questions for conscience sake I'm trying
to remember where that is yeah first as
well it talks about eating it in 1
Corinthians 10:27 the verse we just read
yeah where it talks about ask no
questions for conscience sake but that's
when you sitting down to eat yeah so
don't ask them well was this offered to
an idol the question wasn't what kind of
meat is this or what kind of food is
this the question for them was is it off
offered to an idol he said you know
Pastor yeah let me read the next verse
because I think it makes it very clear
it says Paul goes on he says but if
anyone says to you this was offered to
Idols do not eat it for the sake of the
one who told you and for conscious sake
for the Earth is the Lords and all the
fullness of it so here pretty clear Paul
says you know if it's clean food and
they put it in front of you don't ask
was this offered to an idol but if
somebody says oh by the way do you know
that was offered to an idol Paul says
well well don't eat it then yeah but
don't ask so and there's another verse
where he says whatever is sold in the
shambles in the King James at shambles
it's Marketplace or something and so the
big question they grappled with with is
were they supporting idolatry since all
the Romans and the Greeks offered
animals to the I'm talking about clean
animals goats sheep chickens they
butchered it in front of an idol yeah
there it is 1 Corinthians chapter 10:25
eat whatever is sold in the meat market
asking no questions for conscience sake
yeah so he wasn't say EA any Pig he's
talking about the clean Meats all right
good question Isabella is in North
Carolina Isabella welcome to the
program hiy guys can you hear me loud
and
clear um thank you guys for all you do
first of all and for this live um
basically my question is for chapter I
mean Genesis
19 chapter one if you guys could
elaborate on what's going on and the
angels if they're accepting praise from
lot or not as curious and thank you for
your Jesus in The Bible series oh praise
the Lord thank you all right so let me
read this for our friends that are
listening and Genesis 9 19 chap verse
one I believe now the two angels came to
Sodom in the evening and lot was sitting
at the Gate of Sodom when lot saw the
men he arose to meet them and bowed
himself with his face towards the ground
uh you know that was actually a custom
of greeting it wasn't talking about
worshiping uh you would also you know
you go to Korea and even today when I
meet some of my Korean friends here in
North America as we introduce each other
they sort of instinctively bow it's kind
of like we shake hands uh it was just
considered a term of respect and um uh
Abraham lot a lot of the Patriarchs they
practiced very strong
hospitality and when lot saw these two
dignified uh gentlemen coming into the
city and he knew the reputation of the
city he thought you know I better invite
them home so they don't end up in the
wrong place and so he approached him
right away and bow and said let me let
me offer you a place they had no hotels
back then and people would take in
strangers all the time it's what Paul
says in Hebrews entertaining strangers
unaware of some of entertained angels
but no that he's not worshiping them
okay very good we've got an listening in
Anchorage Alaska an welcome to the
program um yes um I'm praying that you
folks are safe from the storm going by
but my question is um in Mark 5 where um
Jesus healed the uh
um paralytic man um my I'm wondering who
it says that God or that an angel
stirred the pool occasionally and then
everybody tried to rush in I'm wondering
was that an angel of God or was that an
angel of Satan okay because it seems to
me God would offer more than just one
person right healed now first you said
Mark I think you mean John chapter 5
where where the Waters of bet are
stirred yeah
um yeah that is actually a good question
you know it's hard to picture that an
angel of God is going to see all of
these sick people laying around this
pool hoping the water will be bubbling
or stirred and whoever clammers in first
over the other all fighting against each
other to get in the water first is going
to be healed that'd be sort of a
pathetic uh scene I think it's built
around a
Superstition and you know whether it was
a naal natural phenomenon that water
bubbled up every now and then U I've got
a spring like that if you keep watching
this one spot water just keeps bubbling
up um or you know evil angels would stir
it and make the most of it but I don't
think that God was doing that your
thoughts yeah absolutely I think there's
been some archaeological evidence to
support the idea that the PO of Bethesda
was actually built close to or over the
spring and it's quite possible at
certain times there was some sort of
movement of the the water as the spring
would kind of you know Bubble Up and
people saw that and maybe at some point
in time somebody happened to be stepping
down and of course they were all looking
for some kind of Supernatural evidence
they're hoping for healing and maybe
somebody was at least they thought they
were healed somehow can be the placebo
effect yeah that's right and the idea
caught on and so everyone's waiting for
the moving of the water yeah well even
today you know there are tens of
thousands of people that make
pilgrimages and go to Lords uh these
different Catholic shrines hoping to be
and they say that some experience
Miracles so is that Mary doing that or
you got not only for the Catholic Church
there are people who make pilgrimages to
Buddha statues and that say that they're
going to be healed so um I think there's
some counterfeit healings and sometimes
a person might be healed just because of
their faith uh Jesus said many times
your faith has made you whole and um
maybe God honored their faith in God
it's hard to say but a good question all
right we got uh Shannon listening in
Georgia Shannon welcome to the
program um hi thank you um I'm calling
about Romans 3 vers 19 and 20 could you
please explain that all right let us
read that for our friends Romans 3:19
now we know that whatever the law says
it says to those who are under the law
that every mouth may be stopped and all
the world may become guilty before God
therefore by the Deeds of the law no
flesh will be justified in his sight for
by the law is the knowledge of sin all
right would you like us to expound on
that a little
bit yes okay everybody has broken God's
law uh sin is the transgression of the
law the Bible tells us in 1 John 4 sin
is the breaking or transgression of
God's law all have sinned Romans tells
us and fallen short of the glory of God
if we are saved by lawke keeping then
we're all doomed it's not that uh
keeping the law saves anybody we're
saved by grace now when a person is
saved by grace do they continue to break
the law that's why Paul says in in
Romans I think it's chapter 6 do I
continue in sin that Grace May abound do
I continue breaking the law that Grace
May abound he says God forbid how shall
we who are dead to sin continue any
longer therein and then you'll also read
in Romans chapter I think it's chapter
2113 he said it's not the hearers of the
law that are just before God but the
doers of the law that will be justified
and he's talking about saved people who
are keeping the law not to be saved but
because they love the Lord that's why
Jesus said if you love me keep my
commandments so uh is that making sense
Shannon yes okay praise the Lord now you
would enjoy that study guide that we're
offering and we also have a sermon book
that's called does God's grace blot out
the law and we'll send you a free copy
of that or the one written in stone the
number to call is 800 83567 47 that is
our resource phone line you can ask for
the book it's called does God's grace
blot out the law you can also ask for a
free offer for tonight it's called
written in stone you can also dial pound
250 if you'd like to get a digital
download dial pound 250 say Bible aners
live and then you can ask for the book
by name does God's grace blot out the
law thank you Shannon we've got George
in or George welcome to the
program thank you very much for taking
my call the question is in Genesis
3:21 um the Lord God made tunics who
actually do you think uh killed the lamb
was it uh being shown to Adam how to
kill or did the Lord kill the the the
lamb yeah that's a great question but uh
my belief is that God established the
sacrificial system and um uh when Adam
saw and Eve these innocent creatures
that they were originally designed to
name and care for dying for their sin it
broke their hearts I think Adam probably
cried when he saw leaves dying because
of his sin this beautiful garden um so
God established a sacrificial system now
Pastor Ross in Revelation says the lamb
slain from the foundation of the world
and it says God so Lov the world he gave
his son so I think it makes sense that
in the beginning God is the one who EST
establish a sacrificial system showed
Adam I agree I was just going to add a
few more verses where Jesus speaks about
his crucifixion he says nobody takes my
life but I lay it down of myself I have
power to lay it down and take it up
again so Christ is the one God is the
one who provides the sacrifice right and
of course after the first lamb was
sacrificed then throughout the Jewish
system the high priest would the lamb
would be brought and the priest would be
there the Israelite would lay his hand
on the head of the goat symbolizing the
transfer of sins he'd have to take the
life of the goat because our sins took
the life of Jesus but Jesus willingly
laid down his life yeah so I think
Gary's also wondering or George I'm
sorry is also wondering was it God who
actually cut the Lamb's throat or did he
tell Adam what he needed to do and Adam
had to do it mhm I think the first one
it says God made coats of skin so you'd
assume that God was the one that and
again that ties in with the idea of
Jesus laying down his life yeah
absolutely well listening friends uh we
are not done we're going to take a brief
break and we hope that you'll come back
uh we're going to The Best Is Yet To
Come for Bible answers live if you want
to call in with a Bible question it's
not too late 800 God says 800 463
7297 and we'll be answering your Bible
questions also you can be listening on
Facebook and YouTube and AFV be back in
just a
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly
Doug Bachelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control his search
eventually led him to a cave above Palm
Springs that became his home while Doug
scavenged for food and garbage bins his
father owned a yacht A Lear Jet and an
airline but in his cave home he
discovered a dust covered Bible as he
began to read he soon learned of his
true purpose in life the richest caveman
is the extraordinary true story of Doug
Bachelor that tells how a rebellious
teenager who once lived in a cave became
a tremendous Soul winner for Jesus
Christ it's a thrilling testimony of the
transforming power of God's word to
order your copy of the richest caveman
call 8005382583
bookstore.com
are you looking for a simple way to
share your faith if you've ever found
yourself Tongue Tied when trying to
explain what the Bible teaches about the
Sabbath the second coming or the
afterlife you'll love the new amazing
facts tracks these colorful tracks
feature easy to read type and are large
enough to grab everyone's attention but
small enough to fit in your pocket to
carry with you wherever you
go 11 key Bible teachings are available
now
purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save equip yourself and your church
to reach your community with the
eye-catching amazing facts tracks
amazing fact tracks easy to read easy to
share to order your sample bundle call
800 5387
275 or visit AF bookstore.com and get
ready to share your faith like never
before
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that's 800 463
7297 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and this is a live
International interactive Bible study
you can be part of it all you need to do
is pick up your phone call that
toll-free number 800 God says that's 800
7297 you know we've been doing this so
long Pastor Ross we got that number when
800 actually meant you didn't have to
pay for the phone call of course no one
has to pay anymore it's been a long time
been going for quite a while but we
could have any old number now but yeah
you're welcome to call in with your
Bible questions my name is Doug Bachelor
my name is John Ross and we have a
number of folks who are standing by with
their Bible question we're gonna go to
Ryan in New Mexico Ryan welcome to the
program hello guys hi yeah I'm in I'm
I'm here in New Mexico and yeah we've
been getting a lot of that crazy wind
ourselves it has been crazy I been um
yeah um my question is is the uh is the
Gregorian calendar that we all use today
um is is it not the uh the beast power
trying to change times and laws um is it
you know because you know we we know who
the Beast is um do we not and I don't I
I see that uh um basically uh the you
know the the pope and the Roman the
Roman you know it's a Roman Cal
um yeah well let me take a stab at that
yeah no I think I understand um so the
prophecy you quoted is from Daniel 725
speaking of the beast power it says he
will think to change times and laws and
well the Romans changing the calendar
that even predates Christ uh it was
during the time of Julius Caesar they
had the Julian calendar and I think
everyone knows that the reason we've got
a month called July is because of Julius
Caesar and the reason we have a month
called August is because of Octavian or
Augustus Caesar and um the Roman months
actually were very different um October
was like octagon oo That was supposed to
be the eighth month well it's the 10th
month for us December D Deca that's like
a decade that's supposed to be the 10th
month well it's the 12th month so the
Romans did a lot of things at November
no n is supposed to be the ninth month
but it's
not so um the calendar got changed a lot
by the Romans and then it got changed
again the the adjustment that was made
by Pope Gregory or during his time
anyway was actually a good adjustment
they were adjusting for not having the
right amount of days in in the month and
they added you know leaped year and
adjusted it ahead 10 days so that was
just modifying things for farming but um
there are other ways where they tried to
establish feasts that are not in the
Bible and ignore the ones that are the
holy days and the Sabbath day there's a
big effort to change God's holy times
and
laws separate from the
calendar yeah they did certainly mess
with the calendar the calendar as you
mentioned Pastor Doug they never changed
the days of the week right I'm looking
at it here October the 15th they changed
it in 18 1582 and they had Thursday
October the 4th followed by Friday
October the 15th so they just added 10
days yep but they didn't change the days
of the week right
yeah Thursday was followed by Friday as
it always has been yeah and the prophecy
is referring to the beast power trying
to change the day of worship and that's
that's a different story right okay
thank you we've got James in Texas James
welcome to the
program yes sir thank you for having me
my question for the night is the time of
trouble and the Great Tribulation is
that that takes place the seven last
plagues is that the same thing the time
of trouble and the tribulation or is
that two different timelines Al together
well let's talk about the final time of
trouble and you know Jesus he does
reference that in Matthew 24 Mark 13
Luke 17 and Luke 21 and it's also
referen in Revelation 15 and 16 when the
seven last plagues fall out it seems to
come in two stages where you have what
people might call the small time of
trouble during the small time of trouble
there's great persecution you cannot buy
cell unless you cooperate with a beast
but during that time God's people will
still be spirit filled preaching
there'll be many converts uh during that
time uh we don't know how long that is
uh but finally they're going to have a
death decree and when they bring out
this death decree right then or close to
that time we're going to see the seven
last plagues fall probation will be
closed that's called the great time of
trouble so when you've got the oceans
and the Springs turning into blood and
men are scorched with great heat and
they got noisome sword and and you just
look at the seven plagues and it's going
to be pretty intense uh that is the
great great time of trouble such as
there never has been since the
resonation and that's Daniel 12 vers1
yep so what you're saying pastor de is
that um the time of trouble and
tribulation are just two words but they
can refer to the same thing yeah well
every Christian goes through some
tribulation Paul says it is through many
tribulations we enter the kingdom of God
so everyone goes through different kinds
of tribulations but the the historic
great time of trouble that's still ahead
of us okay very good next quer that we
have is Daniel in Michigan Daniel
welcome to Bible an's
live yes hi thank you for taking my
call um someone already asked this
question but I'll ask it anyways okay so
how can you know if you have been saved
or born again I know Jesus says you
cannot enter the kingdom unless you're
born again and I've been kind of
confused about lately I always thought
that if you're willfully giving into
sin uh you know you know it's wrong but
you've give in anyways that's an
indication that you're not born again
because 1 John 3:9 says everyone who has
been born of God does not practice sin
and sometimes I fall under that category
for I don't know a few days few weeks
and I'm thinking am I born again I'm not
sure and um and then I asked a friend
this and he saidwell you can only lose
your salvation if you grieve away the
spirit so I'm like so you can like
practice sin for 10 20 30 years and
still be saved he's like well yeah as
long as you haven't grieved away the
spirit and I'm like I don't know if
that's right so like what do you think
that's yeah good question you you
articulated very well a question many
people ask um well first of all how do
you know you're born again uh who has
your heart uh who do you like to talk
about you can tell when a person loves
football because they're always talking
about football or airplane whatever is
in their heart Jesus said out out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
and when you receive Christ in your
heart and you love him and he's giv you
a new life you're going to want to tell
other people you're not going to want to
do things that offend him that doesn't
mean it will never happen but um that
should be the exception and not the rule
so people that are living a life of sin
they may have been born again once but
they're they're uh they stepped away
from it and they need to be
reconverted um you know I did a sermon
Pastor Ross just a few weeks ago and
it's titled uh do you need to be perfect
to be saved and I address this that you
know what's the difference between
falling you know you slip up you sin and
living a life of sin and how perfect we
need to be uh to be saved so you might
want to look at that just on YouTube
Type in Doug Bachelor and and uh it'll
pop up you know the Apostle Paul says
speaking of this I Die daily so this
conver this being born again isn't just
a one time thing and then we go on sort
of just you know living in a cloud no
Paul says I Die daily in other words
every day we need to surrender to self
every day we need to ask the Lord for
the Holy Spirit to give us Victory and
to sustain us and help us overcome so
it's a day-by-day experience and as long
as we are trusting in the Lord we are
seeking his strength and his guidance we
can have assurance that God is going to
be with us and he's going to finish the
work that is begun so we can take heart
amen thank you Daniel we've got Alfred
listening in Canada Alfred welcome to
the
program yes uh thank you for taking my
call yes sir uh I was I was wondering
why is Jesus called the son of David I
mean between David and J there's about a
thousand years Span in between there so
why would he called the son of David
yeah great question um there's a prophet
named Nathan and Pastor Ross might find
that I think he can find it in uh 1st
Chronicles
17 and Nathan the prophet comes to David
and he tells David that your son that
will come after you he will build me a
house that will last forever and it's a
prophecy it's called a Messianic
prophecy that God says Not only would
the Messiah come through the Seed of
Abraham and Isaac and Jacob and Judah
but then God Narrows the focus he says
and the Messiah would come through the
line of David and you can read one of
the first things it says in the New
Testament it gives the genealogy of
Jesus and it traces it back to David So
when every Jew believed that when the
Messiah came it would be from the line
of David and um that's why they often
called him the son of David it was sort
of another title for the
Messiah all right very good yes and
you've also read about that in First
Kings chapter 5 where it talks about
Solomon yep who built the house so
that's sort of what you call a dual
prophecy you have the literal son of
David Solomon who built the literal
Temple but of course it's in a broader
sense speaking about Christ and the
temple that he was to build was the
church so there's some parallels there
all right thank you Alfred we've got Tad
listening in North Carolina Tad welcome
to the
program thank you for taking my call
it's my first time calling so bear with
me thank
you the question I have is um is about
the Millennium A Thousand Years yes and
I know that you know in 1 Thessalonians
41617 is that the righteous will be
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
and I believe that's the beginning of
the Thousand Years and but then you go
to Revelation chapter 20 I've been
taught to believe that um you know that
the Earth is desolate for a thousand
years there's no one living except for
the devil and his angels during that
thousand years on this planet but in uh
in in Revelation chapter 20 it seems to
elude uh let's see it says here in verse
two of chapter 20 it says he laid hold
of that the dragon that Serpent of old
who is the devil and Satan and bound him
for a thousand years and cast him into
the bottomless pit and shut him up and
set a seal on him so that he should
deceive the Nations no more till a
thousand years were finished but after
these things he must be released for a
little while and then there's an interl
there um about those who were beheaded
and then it says says verse 5 but the
rest of the Dead did not live again
until a thousand years were finished
this is the first resurrection and it
says and he's loose for a little season
after the Thousand Years to go out and
deceive the Nations that are in the four
corners of the earth so it see it sounds
like that these nations are still in
existence during the Thousand Years on
Earth okay let's talk about that so um
to specifically answer the question
you're asking when the New Jerusalem
comes down well first of all let's let's
do it sequentially so when Jesus comes
the righteous go up the righteous in
Christ are resurrected the dead in
Christ rise all the good go up when
Jesus comes are we
together now I read it too okay then it
says we live and reign with Christ for a
thousand years in Revelation then you
read it says in chapter 21 the New
Jerusalem comes down that means it's
somewhere else now it comes down from
Heaven to Earth when Christ comes back
the Bible says in in Revelation 20
there's two resurrections you got the
resurrection of the just and the
resurrection of the
unjust uh Christ said the hour is coming
in which all that are in the graves will
hear his voice they that have done good
the resurrection of Life they that have
done evil the resurrection of damnation
that's the second Resurrection that's
why it says blessed and holy is he that
has part in the first resurrection you
don't want to be in the second
Resurrection so the second Resurrection
takes place at the end of the 10,000
years this looses Satan from his prison
he now has this vast army they call them
Gog and Magog that they were the enemies
of God's people in the Old Testament
that he can attempt to manipulate to
attack the city of God so that explains
why there are nations alive as they've
been it's a wicked of all ages have been
raised so so far does that make sense
even if you don't agree I'm does the
logic make sense yeah yeah that does I
mean it does elude it seems to sound
like you know cuz I I've not been raised
to believe that there's any any uh
Nations alive on the Earth but I've ran
into people it's becoming more and more
of a prevalent idea oh yeah out there
keep in mind I haven't I haven't touched
the surface yet I you know I wish I had
an hour by the way I've got a
presentation on this on Thousand Years
of peace that you can watch online but
you read in Jeremiah
4:23 it says all the cities of the Earth
are broken down and there is no man and
they this is from the coming of the Lord
by his presence and fierce anger you can
read in Isaiah where it says I will make
the Earth utterly empty and then
Jeremiah says the slain of the Lord will
cover the Earth from one end to another
there is nobody to mourn or bury them
those who believe that the righteous are
always alive or someone's alive
righteous or Wicked on Earth they can't
explain these scriptures that say the
Earth is vacated during the Thousand
Years so I think there's a lot of
scripture to support that we are caught
up we meet the Lord in the air all the
righteous are gone during the Millennium
at the end he comes back the wicked are
judged he creates a new Heaven and a new
Earth now we have that study guide
Pastor Ross we do it's called a thousand
years of peace and it goes into great
detail gives you all of the Bible verses
makes it very clear so we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 8835
6747 you can ask the study guide It's
called a thousand years of Peace you can
pound 250 on your smartphone and say
Bible answers live and then ask a
thousand years of peace and we'll be
able to send you a digital download of
the lesson so either way you can get
that thank you Tad great question we've
got uh Henry in New York Henry welcome
to Bible ansers
live having new uh during crisis time
what language do this do the Roman speak
all right during the time of Jesus what
language did the Romans speak they spoke
Latin and Greek they spoke Latin as
their native language but many of the
Roman soldiers not only came from Rome
but they would also Annex soldiers from
different parts of the Empire and Greek
was sort of the language like English is
the international language for business
Greek because of Alexander the Great's
broad Conquest was sort of the language
of learning writing and business so
everyone spoke some Greek that's why
above the head of Jesus when they posted
why he was dying they had to post that
in three languages Hebrew for the locals
Greek and Latin okay very good next
caller that we have is Jay in California
Jay welcome to the
program thank you pastors for taking my
call I I had a question and a probably a
concern in a question but I just wanted
to know um the uh the text Leviticus 7
26 and 27 and I also failed to mention I
guess Leviticus
1713 and 14 I would like to know if
those texts are still relevant for today
um that I I've uh because I heard you
know I I'm uh the Bible gives the clean
Meats to eat as far as what Christians
or or his people follow the the type of
diet they follow however I have very
rarely hear um leaders that you know
know about uh that believe as Christians
we are to follow a healthy lifestyle I
very rarely hear anyone speak about not
eating the blood even though God does
give us the clean meat that um that that
uh there is to be no blood in the meat
if we eat it because I understand that
even if it's Kosher meat there's a
little bit of blood in the kosher and
then the taste is no longer in the um
flesh meat so I just wonder if those
texts are still relevant if so yeah yeah
let Hey first of all let me read it for
our friends that are listening and I'll
actually go back to let me see um that's
Leviticus 7:26 moreover you shall not
eat any blood in any of your dwellings
whether bird or beast whoever eats any
blood that person will be cut off from
his people not only do you find this in
Leviticus it mentions this also in the
New Testament if you go to so people say
that was an Old Testament law oh no it
wasn't you can read in Acts chapter 15
it says you write to the Gentiles these
are non-jews who are turning to God that
we write to him to abstain from things
polluted by Idols from sexual immorality
from things strangled and blood the
reason they said things strangled is
because especially with foul they'd
sometimes strangle it and then theyd
butcher it and eat it without draining
the blood whereas the Jews would cut the
throat and drain the blood out now if a
person is eating a clean meat and it's
been killed in a Kosher Way where the
blood is drained out well that was
permissible I'm sure there's still
microscopic parts of the blood left but
you know that the the Jews um they just
understood you're supposed to drain out
all you can um but uh it is a new and an
Old Testament law and now we know that
blood can transfer disease from one
animal to another it doesn't have to be
the same species that's why you got mad
cow disease and later they had mad pig
disease and Co they believe was
originally incubated in an animal
whether it was a bat or a pangin they
don't know but a disease does transfer
from animal to animal that's why God
said don't be eating the blood of
animals by the way that goes back to
Genesis and I talked about blood too in
in God speaking to Noah so yes Christian
shouldn't eat blood I remember when I
worked with the navo Indians they used
to make blood sausage I thought oh that
gave me the
creeps all right what's next we've got
Hector listening in Florida Hector
welcome to the
program thank you good evening pastors
evening um did the falling of Lucifer
take place uh before or after Man was
created if that's so if this if this
fall after man was created how come God
allow him to tend the man on Earth all
right well I think that Lucifer fell
before Man was created and you know in
part part of the reason God made this
new world and told the creatures to be
fruitful and multiply is to uh help
replace the vacuum of onethird of the
angels that had been evicted from heaven
so I'm pretty sure that the we don't
know all the timing of everything that
happened but pretty sure that Lucifer
fell and the Rebellion happened in
heaven before our world was made what do
you think Pastor Ross absolutely I mean
if you read the context just in Genesis
12 it talks about this war in heaven and
then the devil the Lucifer the dragon is
cast out of heaven and then it says he's
cast down at the cross so yeah it
appears that that appeared sometime but
I think he's also Hector's also asking
then if if Lucifer fell before the
creation of the world why did God allow
him to come tempt Adam and Eve well I
think God allowed Lucifer uh he gave him
enough leash to share his perspective
see the reason that these angels
followed Lucifer is Lucifer was allowed
to uh tell the Angels he would be a
better God than God he basically was
saying that God is not fair he's
arbitrary his laws are unreasonable but
if I was in charge we'd have great
freedom and happiness and so God does
not force his creatures he allowed the
angels to the ones who chose onethird of
them followed Lucifer and he allowed the
UN Fallen worlds to be at least tempted
with the same opportunity to doubt God
and listen to Lucifer that's what Adam
and Eve did God said don't eat it
Lucifer said oh he you'll be like God if
you eat it which is what he wanted and
so um yeah that's the reason he did it
okay very good we got Carmen listening
in New York Carmen welcome to the
program good evening pastors uh my
question is on Revelation
14 6 and 7even but more seven um where
it says the hour of his judgment has
come my question is are we being judge
at this moment as R Us yeah I mean well
first of all yeah this is God's last
warning message to go to the world
immediately following the proclamation
of the Three Angels messages in verse 14
it talks about the second coming of
Christ and part of this three-fold
message is the hour of his judgment has
come and of course that's the
Fulfillment of a prophecy finding Daniel
8:4 14 where it talks about the
cleansing of the sanctuary so there's
different parts to this judgment it is a
judgment meaning that truth has been
revealed in the world and people are
making decisions for that truth and
based upon their decision well they're
going to be judged either in favor at
the end they receive the Seal of God or
they reject the truth and they receive
the mark of the beast is this judgment
happening now I believe so in heaven
people are making up their mind uh that
doesn't mean that there's a certain time
when your name shows up in the books of
heaven and could be tomorrow at 3:00 in
the afternoon and suddenly you saved or
Lost based upon where you at there I
think God looks at our life as a whole
and looks at the decisions we are making
but everybody is making a decision we
are settling into the truth and it's the
little decisions that we make every day
that determines what our Eternal Destiny
is once that judgment is finished Jesus
says he that is Holy let him be holy
still he that is filthy let him be
filthy still probation closes seven last
plagues and then Jesus comes absolutely
you know we have a study guide called
angel messages from space and it talks
about the Three Angels messages we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks that's 800 835 6747 or you can dial
pound 250 and the the lesson on God sets
a deed for the Judgment that's right is
also goes dials right in on this all
right maybe time for one more we've got
uh Cammy listening in Washington Cammy
welcome to Bible anwers live
I can't believe you got me in I was so
happy to hear that sorry I wish we had
more
time I send my I set my alarm for this
program so I don't miss I'm addicted to
it oh good we hope it's habit for me
taking my question now this is a
question I've had for a long time I've
been wanting to call you guys I finally
did it and got through did when King
killed
Abel and left and took a sister so they
really lost three kids that day did C
Aban Eve go visit him and let them know
we forgive you we love you we want to
stay connected the way God did with ab
and Eve in the way we should with our
kids you know it's hard yeah it's hard
to imagine that there was no
communication because well there's not
that many people in the world and you do
read when you get to Genesis chapter 6
that the sons of God meaning the
descendants of Seth and Adam and Eve saw
the daughters of me men they were the
daughters of Cain and they took them
wives you know I think they probably
interacted some they had to or that
wouldn't have happened just like Samson
interacted with the Philistines I think
Adam and Eve were still in communication
hopefully they communicated that Cain
could be forgiven if he would repent and
and to turn to God there's no record of
that communication or his repentance uh
so U it's it's uh we're we're hopeful
that they at least are reconciled in
their human relations you know it's also
interesting that mention that Kane moved
out he took his wife and they left he
went to a different place so it almost
he wasn't kicked out no it was his
choice to separate himself from his
parents that's right and listening
friends we're going to sign off here we
do this in a couple of stages and we
just share every week so people will
understand that uh we have satellite
stations carrying the program and
landbase and they have two different
clock so we're going to say God bless
good night to those listening on
satellite for the rest of you don't go
anywhere Pastor Ross and I will be back
in just a moment to do rapid fire
internet questions that have come
in thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back we're going to take your email
questions if you would like to send us
an email Bible question the email
address is Bal questions
amazingfacts.org
Pastor Doug we have uh Coral asking what
is the Bible's perspective on the death
penalty well you know God doesn't want
anyone to perish but there is a penalty
for death or for murder and it was the
death penalty and uh you know God says
eye for eye tooth for tooth life for
life if someone um killed person
deliberately as the Bible says with a
high hand the penalty was execution and
so states and countries that support
capital punishment for the highest
crimes that is biblical okay uh sandre
is asking I heard that uh there will be
animal sacrifices in the millennial
Reign throughout and for all eternity is
this
biblical no I think they they're
listening to someone who believes that
the temple is going to be reinstituted
Ed during the millennial Reign and
there's going to be sacrificing lambs
and I think they misunderstand some
scriptures God's temple in those
passages is speaking of his church and
um we're going to be in heaven because
of the Lamb the blood of Jesus that you
see in Revelation but that's symbolic
there's no death you read in Revelation
21 when we get to heaven no more pain
sorrow or death and that would include
animals death nothing's going to die
okay we have Nissa who's asking should
Christians serve in jury duty knowing
that their decision can affect a
person's life and
freedom well uh there's nothing immoral
with a juror uh being involved in
investigating Justice in their community
so u i you know I've got a friend that
was on called to be on jury duty and it
was involved in with a murder and
unfortunately he had to be exposed to
some awful testimony but uh and there's
no sin in there that and uh it's you
know considered part of your being in a
community part of the Mosaic law said
that there were often trials where the
elders would listen to the evidence and
they served as the jury and they'd make
a joint decision uh even in the time of
Christ they had a even though it was a
kangaroo court they had the Sanhedrin
they had a jury so there's no biblical
moral problem with jury duty I usually
have to try and get out of it because as
a pastor you you can't get locked up for
week on a trial and you can't minister
to people hey thank you listening
friends that's all the time we have for
tonight you can still send us your
internet or email questions at
amazingfacts.org God bless we'll study
again together next
[Music]
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
[Music]
questions